this is a production of Cornell
University so as they've mentioned today
I'll be talking a little bit about the
2016 drought in New York State and how
that impacted agriculture and maybe some
of the implications for water resources
and I just want to point out obviously
Dave is one of my mentors and then
Rebecca banner who is the chief
scientist role of New York State really
great team okay and just in case anyone
forgot we had a drought in 2016 um I
know 2017 was pretty wet so sometimes we
lose sight of what happened just the
previous year but these are just a few
of the headlines from mid-july through
August in 2016 pointing out that this is
the worst drought in you know almost 100
years and it was a big deal but we
wanted to see how severe was the drought
really from a historical perspective so
we're all scientists and we like to look
at these things a little more
empirically so the first thing we did
was analyze 60 years of air temperature
precipitation and snowfall data and
streamflow data throughout New York to
see just how bad was 2016 relative to
the past 60 years and then we want to
know well how was agriculture impacted
by this drought so we surveyed farmers
across all of their state to get an idea
of their yield loss that Konami impact
how they either were or not able to cope
with the drought and and how they
reacted in real-time and then finally
and importantly what does this mean for
water resources why do we care how
farmers reacted and how they were
impacted by the drought so to get at
this we actually modeled crop irrigation
water use throughout New York State and
we did this because water use reporting
by the agricultural sector is it's not
well recorded or known attract because
unless the farmer is using over 100,000
gallons of water in a day or three
million gallons in a month they don't
actually have to report their water
usage and we have over 35,000
farms covering 20% of New York's land
and a majority of those farms aren't
using that much water but you can
imagine that adds up even if a farmer is
only using 50,000 gallons so we modelled
it in sort of an average here a 15-year
mean to get a sense of sort of normal
typical water use and then in a drought
year so what what did it look like in
2016 so our study site is New York and I
love this math because it shows all the
agriculture in New York so this is
fruits and vegetables and field crops
and everything and you can see pretty
obvious the Adirondacks State Park where
there's no agriculture and Manhattan and
then importantly and why we all love the
Finger Lakes and Cornell it's really
dense in the Finger Lakes region they're
Western and then the dots indicate all
of the counties where we had 275 farmers
respond to our drought survey so pretty
good response rate and that was in
August in September of 2016 and you can
also see that just about every County
with significant agriculture we had
farms respond so that was pretty cool
and then we also conducted more in depth
in person interviews with 75 of those
farmers in January and February so kind
of post growing season all right before
I get into my historical analysis of the
drought I want to point out the Drought
Monitor Maps for 2016 and if none of you
are familiar with the Drought Monitor
there's the the website it's really cool
it takes into account more than just
climatological measures so obviously
temperature and rainfall and so on are
important but they also get subjective
opinions so they actually ask farmers on
the ground how are you being impacted by
the drought and that goes into these
maps so essentially I just want to point
out that in 2016
throughout the growing season the
Drought Monitor map did suggest that the
drought got progressively worse
throughout New York State and
particularly here in western New York
and I'm pointing that out because not
only do we have a lot of dense
agriculture in western
or where the drought was the worst but
also I'm gonna present some data
specifically just from that western New
York region today for the sake of time a
and B so that I don't dilute the results
because a lot of the agriculture in
eastern New York wasn't impacted
similarly the drought wasn't as bad so
I'll point out when I'm focusing just on
western New York it's quite striking
that the area of extreme drought is
almost adjacent to an area of no drought
yeah I know it is quite striking and
I'll I'll give you the the link and
connection to my publication at the very
end of this and I do go through and
analyze very discrete regions in New
York State and it is surprising how
different the impact the historical
analysis of the meteorological data and
also the agricultural impact is in just
one region that is directly adjacent to
another so yeah and again in the drought
maps they're taking into account more
than just rainfall and temperature you
know they're thinking about soil types
and other things like that but yeah it
is quite striking okay so for our data
again this is gonna be just for that
western New York region and this is that
historical snowfall rainfall and air
temperature data and that's what I would
call maybe the snow season so it's the
November December of 2015 and then
January February March of 2016 so
basically the the winter and spring time
meeting in - 2016 and then we have
rainfall throughout the growing season
and air temperature throughout the
growing season all of the black lines
are that 60 year average
so 1955 to 2015 all the gray lines for
snow and rainfall or the lower 10th
percentile so in that 60 year period how
load it again and then for air
temperature it's the upper 90th
percentile so in that 60 year age how
hot did it get and then the red lines
are 2016 so
it's pretty striking here that you can
see snowfall was not only below average
for the entire snow season but it
reached historical lows in November
December and March
similarly rainfall was below average for
most of the growing season reaching
historical lows in June we did get that
little peak of rain and August but that
was too little too late the farmers had
already been pretty severely affected
and it didn't compensate for the lack of
snow and rain in the spring summer and
air temperatures were above average for
the entire season reaching historical
record highs in August and September
so all those combined
again in western New York specifically
led to record low stream some of the
lowest stream flows we've ever seen in
the past 60 years dipping below that
historical low in the middle of the
growing season and so that's indicative
of not only depleted surface water
resources but also groundwater resources
both of which farmers rely on either
sleeper irrigation and we had plenty of
farmers tell us not only did their ponds
and streams dry up but their wells went
completely bone dry ok so that kind of
answers the first question how severe
was this drought well according to this
fairly long-term record it was pretty
historically severe especially in
western New York so next question how
was agriculture impacted again this is
just for western New York because the
impact on farms in eastern New York was
a little bit less severe so this figure
is showing on the x-axis the percent
crop looks so did a farmer lose 0 to 10
percent of their crop 11 to 30 percent
and so on and then on the y-axis the
percent of respondents the estimated
losses within those ranges and so the
thing that jumps out to me first is that
irrigated crops which are the the
striped bars fared a little bit better
you can see over half of the farmers
lost less than 10 percent of their crops
and that's actually maybe a typical
annual loss anyway but then if you look
at the solid black and followed purple
bars which are
rain-fed crops you can see that about
half of the farmers lost over 50% of
their crops in western New York and this
is a wide variety of fruits and
vegetables and field crops and different
sized farms and you can also see that
over ten percent maybe about 15 percent
of rain-fed fruit and vegetable crops so
yield losses of over 90% so pretty
extreme and then when we ask them to
reap economic impact
over 80% of the farmers in western New
York said that it was either moderate or
severe and only 1% of all of those
farmers said man I was merely a nuisance
there was really no economic impact okay
so now we're shifting to the whole of
New York State this is all 275 farmers
when we asked them what was it that
limited your ability to maintain your
yields not surprisingly about 70 percent
said either irrigation equipment or
water supplies and so when we asked them
well and this is what we asked them in
August and September what might you have
done differently if you had known in
advance just how bad this drought was
going to be and you can see a relatively
similar distribution for answers
relating to changing their crop types or
diversifying or maybe changing the
planting dates but 22% said we would
have bought more irrigation equipment
and then 36% said we would have done
something else that you didn't actually
list here and that included things like
increasing your water storage so more
ponds or wells and other irrigation
infrastructure really kind of cool
another big chunk of farmers said that
they would have done things to improve
their soil health
so more cover crops less tillage so on
and then another chunk of farmers said
that they would have done something to
increase their economic resiliency so
maybe start doing some of these things
earlier or recover fallow fields or just
increase their ability to feed their
cows
okay so now this is the follow-up
interviews so now we have a sense of
what farmers were thinking in August in
September when they were kind of in the
thick of the drought they didn't
actually know exactly how much they had
lost yet we asked them well what did you
actually do and this is in January and
February during the drought real-time to
cope with this situation seven percent
said they changed their irrigation
management strategy and so often they
told me that many irrigating it really
inopportune time maybe like at two
o'clock in the afternoon and in the
middle of August just so that they can
get through all of their fields seven
percent so they created makeshift
watering systems they were using
fertilizer chemical sprayers to irrigate
they were driving their pickup truck to
their neighbors and just filling up jugs
of water and using hoses and watering
cans basically just desperate times call
for desperate measures 16 percent went
out and bought irrigation equipment and
another 16 percent invested in water
supplies so they dug ponds or they
drilled wells again with the follow-ups
we asked farmers okay so after what you
experienced in 2016 has this changed
your perspective on future drought over
half of the farmer said yes and then
finally we asked them all right we know
what you were thinking about in August
and September in terms of what you would
have done differently you told us what
you actually did differently in 2016 so
now what are you thinking about doing in
the future to cope with future drought
so maybe in 2017 or in the next few
years six percent said they're gonna
invest in irrigation equipment twenty
six percent water sources so again ponds
well streams and so on and then 11
percent are gonna change their
irrigation management routine and this
is a very water focused presentation but
I do want to point this out because Dave
is so proud of this 32 percent of the
farmers said to help them cope with
future drought they plan to improve
their soil organic matter so again cover
cropping reducing tillage adding organic
matter to their soil so that was pretty
awesome they know that healthier soil
increases your resiliency to these
climate extreme
all right so we basically answered
number two farmers were pretty severely
affected especially in western New York
and this got them thinking about drought
in the future they are thinking maybe
it's gonna occur more frequently and how
they're gonna prepare and then we
actually saw them change their behavior
and do things that they may not have
normally done if they weren't in the pic
of a really bad drought so finally well
what does this all mean for water
resources in a fairly water rich usually
relatively humid state like New York so
before I get into our actual crop
irrigation potential crop irrigation
marios I want to point out this great
figure from one of Dave's publications
showing that in a lot of this is just
Rochester New York over about a hundred
year period but this could be said for a
lot of regions in New York State where
we see precipitation the blue line
doesn't quite compensate for potential
evapotranspiration the red line during
several summer months so we have the
summer water deficit and essentially
what that means is there's a period in
the summer even historically speaking
where irrigation could actually increase
agricultural production so you think
about the farmers that went out and
bought irrigation equipment and 2016
they're probably going to use it even in
a normal year because they've already
made that investment but now we think
about this is where my climate change
minds thoughts come in the summers in
New York are predicted to get longer
quote unquote just because the freeze
freeze in length is gonna get longer and
also hotter and drier so this is data
from the North American regional climate
change assessment program and it's
comparing a historical 30-year mean to
this projected future 30-year mean and
this is just for the summer they have
all the different seasons and the entire
United States so you can if you want but
essentially what they're saying is in
the summer temperatures throughout New
York see in the future could increase
anywhere from 3 to almost 60
Fahrenheit depending on where you are in
the state precipitation could decrease
3/8 about 6% and the freeze free season
length could increase anywhere from 20
to 30 days in various parts of New York
so what does this mean well we already
have historically speaking a summer
water deficit here a period in the
summer where irrigation could be optimal
but with climate change we're gonna see
that grave off blob get really big and
tall basically you're gonna have sort of
longer warmer drier seasons which
increases crop water demand longer
seasons and hotter summers which and you
combine that with decreased
precipitation in the summer you're gonna
see a bump in irrigation okay so now for
our what are you smuggling this is a at
the county level in the manuscript it's
actually going to be like the Dec
drought zone level so this one's a
little bit finer scale but basically
this image is showing sort of normal
average year potential crop irrigation
water use and again I'll give you a link
to the manuscript at the end of this I'm
not going to get into all of the
modeling techniques used because that
would be kind of boring
but essentially what you're seeing is on
average most counties throughout New
York State use maybe ten to a hundred
thousand cubic meters of water
throughout an entire growing season so
that's actually not that much water use
with a few counties may be using 100
around eight hundred thousand cubic
meters and then of course we have a Long
Island with sandy soils and they have a
lot of sod and heavily irrigated
agricultural acres but then if we look
like at a year like 2016 it gets really
colorful all of a sudden because now
counties are using on average across the
state eight times the amount of water
and a dry year compared to an average
year some counties 17 to 23 times so for
some regions we were seeing eight
hundred percent increase in water ease
in a single growing season
and that equates to about four billion
additional gallons water being used just
wandering
so in conclusion with this giant climate
change
blob there's various things that could
happen in New York including one day of
mentioned the increased kind of flooding
with these heavy rainfall events but
also maybe more short-term summer
droughts like the one we saw in 2016 so
essentially we're gonna have a lot more
variability and uncertainty in our water
supply so how much is coming when where
and so on and one of the ways farmers
will adapt to this is to increase their
irrigation infrastructure that's not
terribly surprising and we're also not
just assuming that we saw that happen in
2016 we talked to farmers they told us
is a what they wanted to do be what they
did and we'll see what they're going to
do more of in the future and that's
gonna increase agricultural water use
because again even in a normal average
typical year there is a summer water
deficit so it would be ideal for a
farmer to irrigate if they've already
invested in the infrastructure and so
and maybe a dry drought here that could
just maintain their agricultural
productivity but if you have kind of a
normal New York summer that could
actually increase your productivity and
then that could also entice farmers from
other regions in the country to come to
New York and farm if they see this
so for instance in the western or
Midwestern regions where they have much
more long-term severe droughts and much
more limited water resources they might
be enticed to come to New York and start
farming here and so that's just gonna
keep increasing this this water resource
competition and not just in the
agricultural sector but also the other
competing forces and the industrial
sector or residential sectors and then
that feeds right back into the loop of
increased variability and uncertainty in
our water supply so I'll leave you with
this thought and that is given the
economic necessity to you
irrigation to maintain eels maybe even
increase productivity even in a normal
kind of average year in New York State a
lot of the resource managers across the
state need to start thinking about
climate change climate uncertainty and
potentially increased irrigation water
use which is just going to create more
uncertainty in the water supply and this
goes for a historically humid region
like New York or anywhere in the world
but anywhere in the country the whole
southeastern United States need to start
thinking about this and so the questions
that I'm gonna continue to address are a
power farmers going to adapt to climate
change we saw some of that with how they
adapt it in 2016 with the drought and be
how do we protect our water resources
and agriculture in New York State and
keep them both viable they're both
really important for the economy of New
York State and obviously food and water
are two pretty important thanks for all
of us then finally I'll leave you with a
few of our publications so we had a lot
of extension publications come out of
just the survey results if you're
interested in digging in deeper vej edge
scaffolds and what's cropping off our
vegetable fruit and field crops
extension publications Kix if you don't
know about them is the Cornell Institute
for climate smart solutions they're
their briefs are usually geared more
towards policymakers and researchers and
then the north eastern organic dairy
producers Alliance or Association I
can't remember which and then finally
this is our publication that we put out
in December that goes into a much
greater detail of everything that I
covered today and you can also look at
how the different regions throughout New
York were impacted differently and
that's my email address if you want any
of this material or have questions about
the nature that fellowship or anything
and then I'll leave this up that's crazy
so I know it's a lot of text but I also
know that a lot of you are involved in
extension work and you're probably
interested in not just how farmers were
impacted and maybe like what they're
doing but what do they want what do they
want us to do so the last question we
asked on the survey is what do you want
us to do what can and
and researchers and you know extension
agents do to help you cope with and
prepare for drought in the future the
number one response of what the farmers
want is better long-range forecasts and
I told people that and they actually got
on top of it so people like Toby ol and
art say Gaetano who is a co-author on
that manuscript are working on those and
then the number one thing they want to
know more about is drought resistant
crops and then I'll leave the slide up
that you can take yeah and I actually so
I'll repeat that question just in case
you didn't hear us in Geneva the
question was about the amount of drip
irrigation that's used in New York State
relative to other types of irrigation
and off the top of my head I don't have
that exact number I do have it in the
manuscript I think there's actually a
large percentage of irrigation in New
York State is drip irrigation and I've
talked to irrigation experts at Cornell
and some say depending on the crop that
doesn't always actually save water so
obviously that's going to be better than
flood irrigation but drip irrigation
isn't always the best but yeah a very
large percentage of farmers who are
irrigating fruit vegetable crops are
using drip irrigation love apples yeah a
lot of like strawberries apples if you
are irrigating in high tunnels you're
probably using drip irrigation but not
always some use overhead sprayers I
would say some of the really large may
be cabbage farmers and and potato
farmers are using
Center pivots and larger sprayers but a
good portion of drip I think you're
suggesting like if it looks like we
really start putting pressure on water
resources yeah absolutely yeah so these
are some of the things that we need to
start helping if farmers are going to
invest in irrigation infrastructure that
we need to help them think about and I
think and a lot of farmers said that
they want to know like how do I save
water what kind of irrigation should I
be using for different crops these are
things they did want to know so I guess
then that's not us we have to help them
where the researchers yeah consume that
your irrigation water is coming from
wells not always a lot of them are using
ponds on farm ponds or streams a good
number of farms have streams running
through them some of them are somewhat
seasonal and perennial so you know they
may not always be flowing and especially
in 2016 but yeah a lot of farmers just
pump right out of creeks and streams
that sometimes are fed by Springs so
they don't dry off I would say it was
pretty I actually have in some of the
survey results a figure that shows what
portion of the different types of
irrigation equipment and the types of
water sources the farmers are using
surprisingly about 15% said they're
using city water so they're paying
dearly for water to irrigate and I had
one farmer who has an apple orchard said
he used about 10 million gallons of city
water in 2016 he normally uses 3 million
throughout the growing season so yeah
huge was just asking about for those
farmers who are using wells did you also
detect a decline in the quality of water
as a result of the drought and Carozza
increased salinity and cetera yeah I
didn't actually ask them about the
quality of the water but I would presume
yeah whatever water source you're using
is you're getting less and less even
ponds the quality would decrease well
what not with the exception of probably
city water but I didn't ask that
question I would be interesting
follow-up are you is everyone in Geneva
hearing the questions being asked or
should I repeat them what are you most
excited about in terms of adaptation
research yeah so soil health so Dave is
currently working on the New York State
soil health initiative along with Cedric
and a handful of others and the beauty
of increasing your organic matter on
your farm and your soil is that it makes
you resilient against not just droughts
but also these heavy rainfall flooding
events you know and it increases it can
improve productivity and just make your
soils healthier for the plants less
fertilizer it traps greenhouse gases so
it's protecting our water and reducing
climate change mitigation and also
helping the farmer to be more resilient
to potential climate change so yeah I
would say improving soil health is a
pretty easy way to deal with these
things for farmers sometimes it's a
little bit longer term so you know
obviously buying irrigation equipment is
gonna help you the very next year
soil health takes a little bit but yeah
for the long term I would say improving
soil health it is a great adaptation
meanwhile thinking about irrigation
infrastructure to protect yourself
against drought I think you mentioned
early on about some farmers that are
using 3 million or 10 million gallons
what are the reporting requirements for
water that farmers might pump on their
own land and is there a fee or a tax
that's paid to the counties or is that
bare water to pump you know in terms of
water rights I I don't know anything
about how this work to do
I'm not I went to a really cool water
conference in West Virginia awhile ago
and saw an amazing presentation by a
water rights lawyer out of Pennsylvania
and she said basically to sum it up the
eastern seaboard all the northeast
southeast we are the wild wild west when
it comes to water use resources in the
West every drop is accounted for in the
East it's really there are no water
rights yet if it's on your own property
you pretty much own it it's not really
regulated if it's your own pond but
those giant ponds could be stopping
water from getting to other water
resources streams it says cheaper county
water for agricultural use you know are
there any County provided water yes so
the people who are using like city water
that is accounted for they have meters
recording every every drop of that water
being used but yeah it's your on-farm
water used and not City water use they
don't technically have to report it
unless they're using over a hundred
thousand gallons a day they are supposed
to report it but you know it's it's
fairly unregulated and that's I mean
that's just how it's always been and
it's been okay but if we do see more of
these droughts in the future that might
not be okay maybe we need to start
thinking about tapping into other water
resources for farmers and so on can you
repeat that well so yeah that's
something we've thought about and I know
in the southeastern United States so the
question is basically saving the water
catching the water during the rainy
season right and reusing that so for
instance we have these heavy rainfall
events in the springs what and rather
than just let all that runoff and affect
potentially water quality can farmers
keep that and that is definitely one
thing maybe more ditch systems and ponds
on your farm that they're experimenting
with in the southeastern United States
but it would be interesting to to try
that out in New York too and Dave and I
have talked about that a little bit
seems like it could work it's a lot of
investment for a farmer to put in all of
that infrastructure and then you're also
taking land out of production if you're
building you know five acre pond yeah
but that would definitely be if we do
start seeing more droughts in the future
one potential way to deal with it did
anyone in Geneva have questions yeah
yeah I'm interested in the organic soil
because that's new for me and I know
good organic soil is good in Syria
climate like don't weather so but what's
the percentage of war or chemical so you
know American Western New York State
whoa I might have to feel that question
to Dave wolf so the question was what is
the percentage of organic matter in soil
sort of the entire country but also New
York may be relative to the entire
country
well types of sandy soils have very low
potential there's only so much you can
deliver barren sandy soils so they might
be one or two percent organic matter but
a lot of our typical soils home schools
might be three to five percent and
farmers can build that up some higher
than that you know the better the higher
it is the better it is for water holding
capacity and then we actually have a few
pockets truly what called bucks where
else here in which are really just peat
soil it's almost like super higher we're
keep crops and some of the size so kind
of range but I think a big target but
most of you kind of loam soil where I
mean anywhere from maybe a pretty good
so might be as low as 2% and four or
five percent and trying to build that up
and see behind
did that answer your question yes thank
you yeah
I know another question here from Geneva
okay go ahead when you showed the data
that there is a there's a deficit and
precipitation during the summer from the
from the evapotranspiration I know that
when you were doing the water balance
for that sort of thing you can calculate
how much is coming from the from
underground water that's like because of
course planes are not dying every time
during the summer did you take a look at
how doing that specific season because
the drought was so severe how much water
was taken out of the water table and if
the following season that was
replenished or the best sort of
calculation yeah I didn't actually I
didn't do any real field work aside from
being in the field talking to farmers so
I wasn't measuring actual soil moisture
that would have been cool but I'm pretty
sure there is that kind of data
available online probably through NOAA
or USGS where you can look at soil
moisture and I haven't done that yet it
would be interesting I was just
operating under the assumption that
given all the snow and rain that we had
in 2017 that probably the water table
came back up this was a pretty short
term drought not a long term drought
yeah that's a good point there is gonna
be water in the soil even during that
summer water deficit period that plants
will have available and a lot of there's
a lot of Springs and aquifers that also
help farmers even if you don't have
precipitation helping to compensate for
the evapotranspiration but yes I did not
collect the soil moisture data so I
don't know I think yeah in 2016 yeah I
would say so and actually we did in 2017
I was so lucky to have two such
different years we did survey farmers
and ask them about how the heavy
rainfall events and
impacted their farms and their yields
and so on so we do have some of that
data unfortunately we didn't have quite
as great as a response rate um so you
know it's probably not peer-reviewed
journal publishable but perhaps in some
of the extension publication so keep
your eyes out for that sorry I couldn't
answer that question better but yeah I
would say the soil was really dry in
2016 and it probably was it as dry in
2017 a long time going season on 2017
I'd come back up yeah yeah yeah if we
had had another low snowpack year it
probably would have been pretty damaging
reporting issues with the invasive
earthworms and drought related to
increased you know basically drought
because of loss of water retention due
to disturbed soil
oh so yeah I don't even this is new to
me so these invasive worms are more
prevalent during drought is that in
cultivated areas and woodlands also and
that way that basically the swellest
becomes worm castings and it's really
hard to keep farmers at all I haven't
heard anything about it I just wondered
if it came up during the drought it was
harder to yeah no I didn't have farmers
totally anything about the worms but you
know home gardens where you get to the
point where there can be so much more of
activity and so many worms I've hardly
ever seen a commercial farm where
there's death
be public about lubricants it's called
an invasive it has been covered years
yeah they have to deal with so many
other things that's probably bottom of
their list from woodlands you know it's
a bigger issue because the nutrient
cycling be so vast those kind of harms
that the trees are all installed in
Elega annual there's a lot of fast coast
plants eat a lot of nutrients so the
worms are doing so much activity the
nutrients give least activity for the
trees can actually capture well and also
the handsome cuz Emily was saying tend
to be hydrophobic and what they're doing
is greatly reducing the organic matter
the layer of interesting so yeah just
another thing to deal with I guess cool
well I guess with that it's almost 110
if we had another really quick question
I could feel that or we can
organizations anyone up there that's
educating farmers on some of the
information you come up with like say
instead of investing so much into
irrigation equipment maybe more soil
modification and control it's a cheaper
maybe a bit long term longer term
process is there anybody educating
farmers yeah too much organic man yeah
yeah yeah sure right you want to find
that balance is the only way that not
every farmer has six million dollars for
sure yeah so obviously Cornell
Cooperative Extension is incredible
source of Education the soil health
initiative that that Dave and his team
and Cedric are working on is definitely
geared towards right now they're doing a
little bit more
search and surveying but the ultimate
plan is to have a website and handouts
and information and education for
farmers on how to help improve soil
health and so on and then kicks butt
right the Cornell Institute for climate
smart yeah I was referring to what you
information yeah so we do have a plan to
relay this so all of these publications
veg edge is read by vegetable farmers
across all of New York State it's a it's
a publication for vegetable farmers same
with the fruit journal and what's
cropping up
that's all read by the actual farmers so
and it does give it's mostly talking
about the survey results but it does
give some ideas of what all the
different farmers wanted and you
obviously have those resources that
farmers can follow up with that are
listed in those yeah yep yeah this has
been a production of Cornell University
on the web at cornell edu